[Music]
aaron is with us aaron's in lexington hi
erin how are you
good dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
i had to hear you say that telling me
ask hey i want to keep it brief i know
you want everybody to do the same i have
a tricky situation
uh everyone does me and my wife are
going to get a home in the next couple
months
we've been living in my brother's
basement we've paid off every debt
except her student loan and her car but
the tricky thing is my mother
is going to probably be moving in with
us she has a home now but she's going to
sell her home live with us the good part
of that is she's going to probably
purchase 25 of the home where she's
going to be living with us she's going
to sell hers the tricky part of this
situation
is that my aunts her sister is in charge
of her estate has been since my
grandfather died my grandfather knew she
was terrible with money and she is so he
his will he put that she he wanted my my
aunt to be in charge so that she didn't
burn through her estate
but the only problem is my aunt has
never ever once told my mom or me or my
brother how much she got she's never
told us anything this has been nine
years now she's being very difficult
with the fact that now we're gonna have
our mother movement she's asking all
kinds of questions she's
like to be honest she's coming across as
this she doesn't want her too kind of
because she's going to have to tell us
some answers as to what's going on she's
told my mom she just last christmas she
told my mother that she was nearly out
of money and was going to have to figure
out what we're going to do with her
because she's almost out and now we
bring up the proposition she's going to
move with us
and now she all of a sudden what's your
household in 12 years
my household income is about seven
seventy five hundred a month okay you're
not going to like my answer much
well i probably not okay
you shouldn't do any of this
okay
number one you're broken in debt you
don't need to be buying a house
number two you don't let someone who you
have absolutely no idea what's going on
with their finances and you've got all
this conflict going on own 25 percent of
the house you're going to own with your
wife this is a recipe for marital
discord
okay you ain't seen pissed off till you
seem pissed off like your wife's gonna
be when this story ends
right bad idea dude you're putting a lot
of hot sauce in the chili man you is
asking for it okay well what what about
is there anything we can do i think your
mom needs to stand on her own somewhere
and be taken care of by your aunt until
your aunt decides that she wants to come
clean with the finances you don't need
to buy a house anyway for your mom
and you don't need to buy a house with
your mom even after you're in good shape
financially if you want to let her live
with you as a tenant that's fine but you
need to buy your own house after you're
out of debt and not before if your aunt
won't come clean with what's going on
you can hire an attorney drag her before
the judge and have the judge do a full
audit on the finances and expose them to
the family and maybe remove her as power
of attorney
sounds like that is what needs to happen
by the way because barney fife your aunt
is out of control
but that's a side issue that's not when
she owns 25 of your house